good morning John how are you good
morning again I'm doing good
there was a lot of tension in that game
last night added to the fact that we
didn't know if Joe Girardi even survives
if they lose did you feel like that was
part of the storyline whether it was
something that was said or at least
thought of during the game last night no
I felt look I mean everyone rightfully
was talking about Game two and Joe and
all of you know his desires to put his
team in the best situation realized it
just wasn't a good day it wasn't a good
game but getting the game five in it of
itself look I have been I've been around
Joe and I've seen what the Yankees are
what they do and there's a pressure of
managing I thought and I think he has
done a great job under all the
circumstances and I don't think it's
even a question now and nor did I think
it was a question coming into game five
it's like when you're managing the
Yankees it's like a regular-season game
as a starter no one talks to you they
talk to you after the game right when a
postseason they talk to you before after
during anything it's like doing every
game as a postseason press conference
because of the atmosphere that obviously
comes with managing in New York so they
move on now they got the Astros handicap
this matchup that starts Friday night
well I'm sure you know the Astros last
night were they're never gonna come out
and say they were pleased with the
opportunity to be a home series but they
were hoping that thing went 17 innings
right the way the postseason is gone and
the end and just the decisions of
multiple starters and games and it's
been crazy I knew coming in that the
series was going to be awesome as far as
the teams that we have are really good I
never thought it would go in the
direction that it has and anticipating
moves I could not have seen half of them
so I know that the managers and getting
to the next series is a lot of pressure
to do that I think this series even
whether it was the Indians and the
Astros but now the Yankees I just like
the way the American League matched up
but the starpower the
intrigued with bullpens and power
pitching and power hitting you're gonna
see a lot of home runs in this series
and I don't think that trend is going to
change I'm gonna give you a stat that's
gonna blow you away cuz you faced this
guy in your career you have Erin judge
who struck out 15 times in this series
against the Indians Tony Gwynn went one
season over 500 at-bats and he struck
out 15 times yeah I know it's a little
bit different and if you would have told
me the numbers combined for judge and
Sanchez and the Yankees would move on
I'd say no chance no chance but that's
exactly what that team effort has been
able to do and/or the guy that kind of
goes he's no longer under the radar didi
Gregorian and what he's done is been
unbelievable in New York and look that's
why when talking to Joe he loves his
team's grind ability like they just find
ways yes they hit a lot of home runs
swinging this a lot but let's face it
the thing that didn't didn't think was
going to happen in this series was that
the Yankees were gonna have the most
innings pitched out of their starters no
Chan him but that's what gave him a
chance and come back kind of like what
the Cubs did last year when they were
able to line up their starting pitching
and give him some depth so Tanaka
suberino and CC gave a chance to come
back John Smoltz would be calling the
ALCS and also the World Series for Fox
joining us Dan Patrick show by the way
the guy who has the most career hits
office multi is Tony Glynn with 30 you
knew that didn't game I literally if I
could go back in time I promise you I
would stand on the mound and tell Tony
Gwynn down the middle
I wanted let me talk about Strasburg
what it was what was Strasbourg's label
or what is his label as a pitcher only
because it would felt like he was being
labeled soft you know a guy who had to
have everything perfect before he
started even before last night
but was there a reputation a label of
Strasbourg you know I I'm sure from from
the outside and there's so much
discussion look I I think he's the I I
think he's the best pitcher in baseball
that is yet to be totally equipped with
every aspect of it meaning I think he's
had the best four pitches in baseball
right I mean the best pitcher in
baseball is Kershaw
he's got the he's got three of the best
pitches but I think with with what
Strasburg came out of the scene you
think about his personality is not the
same Kershaw there's no he's not the
same a Scherzer and we we summed was
kind of think that everyone should have
the same personality and the same
structure so be it that as it is that
he's kind of dealt with some really
tough beginnings and those tags won't go
away but today he could probably run for
mayor in Washington because that outing
was unbelievable and gives the Nationals
a chance to win it's a little unfair
from afar to cast what you think should
happen until you go inside
sometimes describing the way sir some
things are could be a little different
you know what I mean maybe just not
being as honest and I think that is what
Strasburg is and and will be in the
future look I'm I since he came out I
did his first game I still believe that
we're looking at the best pitcher in
baseball in the next five years
can you sick out of a playoff game no
and I just again how things are reported
who knows and and and what really are
the circumstances that lead someone to
even think like that but ultimately it
worked out right I mean it worked out
the favor of the Nationals but it didn't
John you know if he doesn't walk in and
say give me the ball I mean it's gonna
labeled forever yeah and I think his
previous experience was a little bit
unfair and how the organization chose to
handle it and then it came down on him
three or four years ago but the thing
that always blows my mind is when
circumstances change
everybody thinks every circumstance has
to change but to this point that your
speak you know if no one would have
known anything it would have been better
who did the Dodgers want to face I
really think I really think it in this
case doctors realized you know hey
they're at home so they like that and
everybody who fell off the Dodgers fan
wagon when they thought that this was a
team that much like the Indians went off
and racing and and you know they're not
the same team I think they're mistaken I
think that the Dodgers have the best
situation going form and most pressure
by the way I know the Nationals have
pressure because they haven't won a
series but I'm saying moving forward if
they play the Nationals it becomes the
pressure on the Dodgers because they
haven't been to the World Series in over
30 years so I think that I think they
would rather play the Nationals but
that's like choosing you know two great
teams only because the Cubs in what they
want going through last year if you're
looking for storylines and who could
help take the pressure off of you it
might be the Nationals with all the
pressures that both those clubs have
been dealing with in the postseason but
I said it the top four teams in each
league and even Arizona
I mean Arizona could have easily no I
don't think a lot of people would have
been surprised if Arizona the Dodgers a
better series Johnny get some rest we
will be watching on Friday night I'm
looking forward to it's gonna be a lot
of fun there's some there's a six foot
eight 5 foot five if I said you could
have judge judge or Altuve depends are
you talking about basketball football
baseball you're you're starting your
baseball team you want Altuve judge
Kalia such a that's such a great
question and I'm not going to get caught
up in the now there I think you know I
wish they played the same position and
answer that but but right now it's hard
to go against Altuve and what he's what
he's done and and what he means to his
club and
my gosh I mean four straight 200 hits
you know plays a position stays healthy
place huge and and just can't help but
but room for a guy like that they're
both great and I want to say this I hope
and I and I hope we get to see Aaron
judge continue in the way that he's
going and I don't mean you know striking
out I mean the ability for him to to
adjust and be a professional this kids
doing it the right way I love the hands
of the baseball is in good hands let's
put it that way
now Congrats on Michigan State's party
beating the Wolverines there mother
nature helped us out again it's alright
you take a win John any way you can get
it absolutely thanks bud alright thanks
John Smoltz he called the game last
night game five Yankees in the Indians
he's got Game one ALCS coming up Friday
night on Fox Sports 1 and the World
Series as well the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience